it's insane this whole this guy's life
is insane is what i can see from this i
mean this guy's
his steroids are you know as good as his
cookies i would say
that's what yeah i want the hgh drop
i feel like i can rule
you look fantastic you upgraded uh i'm
currently recording i wish i could turn
the camera around but i don't want to
screw it up but i'm sitting at my friend
jack's house in hawaii where i'm having
a week vacation
congratulations well deserved uh yeah
yeah
it's it's cool uh just got here but
uh going to be here for maybe five days
but it's all right
how's uh things going with you
yeah things are good did you see um this
thing that the
these guys who tweeted at us that were
like dude we will pimp out your
your stream did you watch these videos
that they made no
i've been flying but they said that they
booked a
ticket to austin are they actually going
to our to my house i don't know if they
i don't think no no they're they're
waiting for us to be like yes or no
but uh these guys applied very
intelligently i gotta give them credit
so basically they saw that we were
trying to upgrade our stuff
and they're like we'll do this for you
we'll make it no hassle i'll come to you
i will hook it up
and a few people tweeted tweeted
something like that at us
and you were like kind of you know
humoring it i guess
and then these three guys are kind of
like i think they're like college
seniors or something like that i don't
really know didn't look too far into it
but they sent us a video they go watch
here's what we're gonna do
and they recorded a video and it looks
like a casey neistat
video like the quality is like that and
the editing style and storytelling is
like that
there's a funny video it was basically
telling us how to
how they would pimp out our stream and
uh they kept calling it like you know my
first million to the moon
and they're like we're gonna take this
baby to the moon here's how we're gonna
do it and so they did two things
he he showed how his camera set up how
they do it for their podcast and it
looks awesome looks way better than ours
and then um also he's then the next day
he sent us an edited
clip of a con of you telling the story
of
bumping into the silk road founder at a
party and he like stole your girl or
whatever
and um they edited like a little clip
and they're like dude we'll pump out
clips like these all the time
my first million to the boom baby and uh
are they good they're good they're
really good
both videos are really good first of all
why let's hire them
and second time where did they send this
to on twitter
i've been flying since saturday it's on
twitter i sent you a link because i was
like
dude [__] yes this is like this is you
know like it's like the opposite of a
job application normally you get a job
you you you put a job up that you want
to hire somebody to do x
and then some people apply and then
you're like are you kind of squinting
you're like
do i think this person's really going to
be able to do it
and then you make a guess and then it
takes some [__] six weeks to ramp up
and then or or this guy just applies
showing
look i can do it i've done it for myself
i'll do it for you
and uh let me make this easy for you let
me show you how bad i want this and i
just thought like
this is so much better than than what
we've been talking about of trying to
find people to do this stuff
i'm looking at his okay cool his name is
dylan
jardin weird last name i keep because i
want to say jordan
uh yeah dylan if you're listening to
this let's do it i'm in
um and you know i don't know there's
probably people with the hustle who have
similar jobs but i think we should
reward the hustle
of these guys and be like the gig is
yours to like
pimp out our the video side of our
podcast i think we should give we should
give them the the chat
all right i'm in cool um all right we
have a bunch of topics you wanted to
talk about where do you want to start
you wanna start with this open salary
thing
no let's start with food because was
this yours
yeah i've thought about this for years
so i have a lot of
i've got i've got something boiling up
so you want to leave
let me intro this all right so i'm
talking to ben my right hand man ben
and ben's kind of like uh you know i'm
easily excitable
you could tell by the way i talk ben is
the opposite he's chill mode he's always
relaxed
and um but when ben mentions things i've
learned like when he says something is
just like
like oh this is cool you should check
this out it's actually [__] amazing
and he just doesn't
say hey dude he doesn't like shake you
and say look at this this is amazing
and so he showed me this thing that is
amazing so he goes
check out this website um or this
instagram handle my cookie dealer
i was like my cookie dealer so i go to
it you should click this oh my god
i'm looking at it now i want to eat this
dude so all right so he sent me three
instagram accounts he sent me buy cookie
dealer click the second one
one 900 ice cream so like 1 800 but 1
900 ice cream
1900 ice cream looks so good
just like describe what you're seeing
it's incredible is it a pie i don't know
what this is exactly like what you would
call it
but it's a it's a cone what it what i
don't know what shape
it is it looks like it looks like
there's a stick so like at the top of
the stick where you would have like a
popsicle instead it's like a full ice
cream concoction
which is like the ice cream and all the
toppings and the fudge on top or
whatever
it looks amazing you should if you have
instagram go to go to 1 900 ice cream
there's one called the cupcake
wonderland which is uh vanilla ice cream
rainbow sprinkles strawberry marshmallow
icing
so they call themselves they call
themselves the ice cream uh thirst trap
slash thick check trademark um and and
they
uh they have a bunch of followers
they've they've grown really quickly uh
26 thousand followers
so ben was sending me these and i was
like okay cool food account on instagram
that's not too new
what what what do i care about this food
porn he's like no no dude i've been
trying to send you one of these
and i've been trying to like get these
myself they do weekly drops
of their stuff and these are selling out
instantaneously so i go what do you mean
so he showed me my cookie dealer so my
cookie dealer does a drop a cookie drop
every week they do a random cookie drop
so a different flavor or whatever
and it sells out within literally
seconds and they're doing 200 000
a week they're doing 10 million dollars
a year dropping cookies
on instagram and just instantly selling
out and then they ship them you know a
few days later
they know how many orders they get and
then they ship them out a few days later
um kind of like you know nationwide or
whatever and
there's another one ally's banana bread
go look at this banana bread dude
just look at this banana bread i want to
print this banana bread out and just
lick the paper it looks so good
and same thing sells wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
dude check check this out so if you go
to
uh mycookiedealer.com that's the website
okay click click instagram page are you
on their instagram and tell me when
you're on their instagram page
i'm on it okay you see go scroll up to
their profile
and you see who where it says like the
owner is this guy named juan diesel
moore
morel click it oh dude he's like a
bodybuilder
this guy is huge
this guy is so big he looks like if
you've ever seen an espn or whatever
bodybuilding competition where the guys
are like this crazy color of skin
that nobody is and he's just humongous
no i i can't tell if it's like the tan i
think it's a black guy
is he like he's so dark i think it's a
white guy you know
like the white guy black tan for
bodybuilding
well and then look at his wife it's
insane this whole
this guy's life is insane is what i can
see from this i mean this guy's his
steroids are
you know as good as his cookies i would
say that's what
yeah i want the hgh drop this is awesome
man
this is cool okay so ally's banana bread
so ali's banana bread so there's a bunch
of these so ben
is like d knee deep in this world of
like instagram
food brands that are basically they're
kind of like
drop shipping baked goods all around the
country so they have them for cakes ice
creams
banana breads and they're just
specialists and so there's a couple cool
things that i wanted to bring up about
this and i know you have some stuff on
food too but
the part that i thought was cool is so
the internet is
the internet is really good at doing
this which is normal before the internet
you would just go to whatever's like
your local whatever so you'd find the
best within your local radius of five to
ten miles or whatever it is
that's what you would go by but with the
internet whether it's news
or comedy or whatever the best thing can
just get distributed everywhere
and so the best brand wins on the
internet and so this is why you see
things get so big you know
like facebook and other platforms
because the best
the best thing will get all the users
and it's what's interesting is that
these guys are doing this with food so
if these guys really do make the best
goddamn banana bread or best cookies or
best ice cream
they don't need a physical shop they
could just through instagram alone
spending zero dollars on marketing have
customers
worldwide like ali's banana bread
literally ships worldwide
and um so if you're the best at making
something now
you have a pathway to become like a
multi-millionaire
um where that really wasn't possible if
you were just a local baker in whatever
in cincinnati
you know you were always restricted by
however many customers you could get
into your local radio so i thought
that's
pretty cool the second thing is if you
think about this
you know this is like a mix of a bunch
of things that we've been talking about
for a while
so we've been talking about cloud
kitchens so these are essentially
like cloud ice cream shops or cloud
bakeries they don't have like a physical
storefront
necessarily they're all in the cloud and
you just order online
the second thing is direct to consumer
so they're going direct to their fans
they're getting their fans phone numbers
and so that when they do a drop they
just text everybody like
one picture of the new thing and then
instantaneously people buy
and i think that's kind of like amazing
a way to go to direct to consumer you
don't have to worry about getting on the
shelf
at you know whole foods or wherever else
to to build your your brand as a cookie
company or whatever
and go ahead no keep going last one is
if you think about it like you know
who's going to be the next mrs fields or
ben and jerry's
or like auntie andy's pretzels it's
gonna be one of these brands it's gonna
be one of these cloud bakeries
doing it on instagram building a cult
following like these guys are doing
and um and you're gonna see i predict
you're gonna see just like
um i forgot what was the name of that
meme company that sold for like a
hundred million dollars they had like
they were the ones behind um daquan
and whatever like a couple of the meme
instagram accounts uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that was about
eight months ago maybe
yeah we talked about it on the pod it's
like we'll pull it up
just like what you see it's right there
you see it i can't really
i am gm media so so basically you know
some brand that just owned a bunch of
like meme accounts on instagram sold for
like 100 million dollars i think if i
remember correctly
you're going to see the same thing in
the food space you're going to see a
bunch of private equity companies
coming in and they're going to buy up
you know alleys
alleys banana bread they're going to buy
up 1 900 ice cream because they're going
to be like
dude this is the next ben and jerry's
and we're going to take this this thing
we're going to put it on steroids we're
going to advertise the [__] out of it
and then we're going to get it into
retail stores on top of what it's
already doing
and so you're i think you're going to
see a bunch of these if i could go
invest in those four brands that we
talked about right now
i would go give them each you know 25k
check because i think these are gonna
get scooped up
okay so let's break this down further
i've thought about this a ton the reason
i've thought about this ton is
i i'm a media guy right by the way is my
mic good
yeah you're good all right i'm a media
guy i love content and i've studied
what goes viral and why for years and
one thing that i've always been
fascinated with is i've known
people who have worked at thrillist and
thrillas started as a food
well they started as like things to do
in new york but one of their biggest
things is food
and i remember when i started dating my
wife she was from new york city and i
hadn't been there since i was
the first time i've been there was when
we started dating 26 27 years old and i
went there and i would see these
long like i would go to like the areas
that you see in movies where like the
cute people hang out where they all
dress like
you know like they dress like right they
go yeah like they just
like for me that was like wow i feel
like everyone looks like a movie star
everyone was cool and hit by you know i
don't i don't know madison square park
or washington
whatever those parks i don't know i
don't spend a lot of time there but you
know what i mean
uh they would have the longest lines and
i'm like what what are all these people
waiting for
and it was like the latest uh thrillers
craze that went viral and so i i would
walk or through brooklyn and everything
and i would see these lines and i'm like
what is going on and i would do research
and i
kind of broke it down into i like i've
like studied this for a while
and uh or not studied is the right word
but thought about it a lot and i
basically
broke it down into the into a handful of
categories
and what it appears what what seems like
what happens is people have a small
store
a relative like pretty like a corner
store in hit
parts of brooklyn or new york where
there's uh people who share so like
college kids mostly
and they create one or two things that
that
thrillist or buzzfeed or someone because
all those companies are located in the
cool parts that i'm describing in soho
things like that
and one of these uh buzzfeed or
thrillers folks sees it
a whole bunch of college kids see it and
then it creates a line and it creates
hype
it it becomes like a good business that
lasts for three to six months and then
it kind of like goes away and maybe like
it still is a remainder but like
still as a business but it mostly like
is a hype cycle whatever
and i was like what is going on and so i
broke this down into a few categories
and i want to go through these
categories because i agree with you i
think this is so cool
and i've tried to break this down so
first
and these are like uh different ways to
say columbus for virality yeah like
formulas for food virality okay
the first one is make a side ingredient
so something that's normally a side
ingredient
make it the main thing so the best
example of this is cookie dough there's
a lot there's like this is a thing i saw
in new york
uh there was a line out a door the door
for someone sold cookie dough as if it's
ice cream so it's like sprinkled cookie
dough then like ice cream flavored
cookie dough it was like
cookie dough is the main thing another
one is cheese like people do
like fondues they have like fondue bars
something that's uh
what else is a side ingredient that
could be it i don't know if it's a side
ingredient exactly but
uh cereal does this too there's there
was these like viral things there's like
cereal bars
all you do is it's just milk and cereal
and that's it and you can come
normally that's not a restaurant it's a
side like it's like literally a side
dish of a side dish
and they made it the focus of the
restaurant and that made the restaurant
notable and remarkable for people
to talk about and go to or an eye or a
whipped cream
like a a whipped cream store just like
anything that is typically
an afterthought that is a topping or a
side to the main
thing make that your thing okay the
second one
is doing the have normal foods but
different colors
a few examples rainbow bagels okay crazy
popular they're they're hype i mean
they're still popular but they went
through
a cycle the second one is rainbow
rainbow kettle corn
that's quite popular when i was a kid i
remember a couple times
buying green ketchup do you remember
green ketchup yeah dude
i love green ketchup it was just red
ketchup but green right it was literally
just the color looks different it's just
the name
just a normal thing but a different
color and then the latest trend on
uh uh or this year on tick tock was
cloud bread which is basically
you know everyone is baking at home now
it's just bread that's kind of blue and
white and looks like a cloud
right and by the way your side thing
main thing i got another example of that
but you know captain crunch the crunch
berries were always just the extra
and then they came out with captain just
just the berries just the crunch berries
it was like way more popular yeah or
like lucky charms with only the
marshmallows yeah exactly so you you
take the thing that's supposed to be the
top yeah the topping the second the
third string thing make it the first
string thing
right okay the third one the same thing
but a different side
uh different size this is pretty common
so like huge pizzas that you can't fit
through the door
huge sundaes they call it like the
kitchen sink everything but the kitchen
sink
in a kitchen sink or or sushi rito is
another example have you seen
sushi rito that's a chain right yep so
it's just
sushi that isn't cut so it's just a long
piece of sushi
uh another one uh i had a friend named
seoul you probably know him
and he created a kitkat bar that was the
size of like a cake
he he would make these things and so
i've actually never seen this sold
but you get the idea a kitkat bar that's
that's like a the size of a loaf of
bread
in san francisco they have this place
bob's bob's donuts or bob's whatever
yes and they have this humongous donut
it's like this
donut the size of you know two of my
head and uh
and you could buy it and then you could
try to eat it and you could take
pictures of it because you're eating
this
enormous doughnut boom that's the whole
book it's not special
but i mean it becomes special it's just
a normal thing but a different size
okay or like in st louis the whole thing
is this is so
silly how this works and st louis our
pizza is cut into squares
right right right so it's around you
kind of said one earlier about like
sushi sushi sometimes it comes in these
like boats or if you go to a beer place
and they serve it in a boot
or whatever it's like it can also be you
know a punch bowl that's in a fish
you know fish bowl or whatever yeah like
it could be bigger and in a
you know in a non non-traditional like
the kitchen sink in a non-traditional
container yes the same thing but
different size okay
or it could be miniature you know just
something that you know
whatever uh like white castle mini
cheeseburgers
uh okay so the the fourth one combine
two things that are quite different okay
so i've got a this is a really easy one
there's a ton of examples the first one
is the crow nut
pretty easy right the latest trend right
now on tick tock pancake cereal
it's i don't even know what it is
there's like recipe i don't even know
what it is but it's
i don't know okay uh look it up actually
while we're talking to brayu
it's probably it's probably just
i i don't know probably pancakes and
cereal okay
no they uh they bake it they call it
pancake cereal it really it's just
probably normal cereal made out of like
the same ingredients they just bake it
at home and it looks like the shape of a
pancake
same with donut cereal but there's um
uh do you know do you remember ramen
burger
yeah okay so there's ramen burger
there's fairy bread you know what fairy
bread is
no what is that it's basically just
bread with sprinkles okay
so you're just taking two things that
don't normally go together
chips and you mash them just like a
dessert burger
uh right very simple or you can get a a
cream cheese bell pepper sandwich
right and the more um more unusual it's
you know it's doritos
locos tacos right it's uh when kfc came
out with the fried chicken
bun or whatever and i was like the bun
is fried chicken um
like you know there's the more
shocking i would say the better in this
case yes you just take two things
you smash them together pretty easy
relatively simple
okay the fourth thing or the fifth thing
is you make
something that's normally a crappy food
but you make it
fancy so tater tots mozzarella sticks
you add a fancy stick to them or you
probably go
the opposite way of making something
pretty uh fancy and make it not fancy
although that would might be gross
but you get the idea and then the final
one is you
uh take um some type of food allergy
but this one isn't actually that sexy if
you take some type of food you just make
something for food allergies so there's
banza which
is a chickpea pasta there's uh
there's uh lou ellen's ice cream i think
it's called in brooklyn it's vegan ice
cream only vegan ice cream
right uh or like oatly is like this
right it's milk not made from cows boom
this is now so popular that this almost
can't go viral anymore
but um maybe if you chose some category
that's not not typical
but it feels like a lot of these are now
mainstream
um at this point
here's what i would do is i would open
up
this was what i was thinking about do i
mean i would never i don't think i would
do it but maybe one day i would want to
actually it seems pretty fun
is i would have a kitchen in new york
and i would get it in a really high
trafficking
high traffic area and i would just every
three months
try to do a launch where i launched like
a rainbow cheesecake
or you know i don't even know i'm just
making you're just making stuff up
and then i would even what i would do is
i would mix i would do a ton of stuff
and then just post a picture and drive a
little bit of traffic to it
and see what had the the cheapest cost
per click
right yeah so so what you're saying is
just reuse the hype cycle no embrace
that the hype cycle exists
and just make a kitchen that's going to
rotate every month into a new
crazy concoction and people will line up
every month to
go try the new thing and you'll build
your brand as like willy wonka when he
would create
you know now everlas everlasting
gobstoppers or
whatever you know like he creates a new
a new crazy concoction that you gotta
go it goes a step further so do you
remember cronut
yeah so cronuts got popular in 2013 it
was invented by a guy named dominique
uh what's his last name i don't know
what his last name is but uh a french
pastry chef he's like a big name chef um
but he made cronut because he likes he
was like i just want to have fun and
create something new and interesting all
the time and this one just kind of hit
he actually trademarked the name cronut
and he is like a purist he's like an
artist so he didn't actually want to
license it to people but he easily could
have made
tens of millions or more by licensing
that name to someone
and so there's a step further so you
create the food and you got to come up
with a really cute name
and you could actually get a trademark
and and there's licensing deals there
so i think this is super fascinating i
think if someone invested one year of
their life to do this and
a hundred grand or less they could
probably get one or two hits
right um which may not be the right
thing to do with your life but if that's
you
if you're like i'm doing it great great
good it's definitely fun
it seems fun but yeah it'll teach you a
lot i think it'll teach you a lot about
business and marketing to be able to
approach
you know food this way um okay so a
couple other opportunities i see here so
i mentioned i think you know investing
or private equity i think will start to
scoop up these brands i think that's one
opportunity
second one is i think somebody could
could build a kind of guy fury of
instagram food
uh character who basically just goes and
tries to find
the next you know who really does make
the absolute best like oatmeal
or whatever right like come up with like
you know go to every category
and then just hunt for the best one ever
and then you do the drop
on instagram you know for that brand for
that for that shop and maybe you
you found you know the absolute best
philly cheese steak in philly
and then you uh you know you dropped
that so i think somebody could create
that if they were if that's what if
they're foodie and that was their thing
the other thing is a little more boring
which is like we've talked about um
cold chain 3pl so basically how the heck
do you ship all this stuff
um and keep it where it actually tastes
good when it arrives you know three to
five days later
uh across the country how do you how do
you make it work and so
i think that there's just a bigger a
bigger and bigger need for
cold chain logistics um and and i think
we've we've heard this a few times now
and i feel like if somebody's working on
that or somebody has one of those i
would love to
talk to you just to learn because i
think this business is booming and i
think more and more people are going to
go into it
okay do you want to hear one more food
thing that we could to discuss
do you remember as a kid seeing these
books i'm pulling them up now
called eat this not that no what is that
okay so it was awesome i loved it i
bought it once just because it was at
barnes noble
and uh it ended up like being like
pretty amazing so google eat this not
that
it started as one book uh like almost
like coffee table-esque
book right and on the left side it says
eat this and on the right side is
not that and so for example um it
started as just like a general
a general one but then they eventually
went to like desserts
fast food all types of that all types of
stuff like that and
an example let's find an example one
that i could say so it would say
eat this arby's beef cheddar classic
450 calories 20 grams of fat not
this arby's roasted turkey ranch
sandwich which has 800 calories and so
it shows two things
that are quite similar and it says eat
this one instead of this one right and
if i want to say eat a salad don't go to
arby's it's saying like if you're at
arby's get this one not that one
yeah or let's see if like they have like
different den
different denny's breakfasts or uh like
ihop versus denny's
or whatever eat this or uh yeah you get
the idea right
yeah okay it's are you looking at you
google it
yes it's pretty sick i it's been around
since probably 200
uh probably 2002. i mean i think i
bought this when i was
pretty young um let's see
there's a whole half a million followers
on instagram which is like
i think all these old like kind of
publications like either magazines or or
little brands like this today they're
all just instagram accounts i think
that's the way to like reinvent these
wow okay so they eat this not cat eat
eat this not that as of 2012 had sold
eight million copies of the book right
and then they spun it up into a magazine
and wow it's
freaking amazing i'm just pulling this
up um here's what i would do right now
today
if i wanted to get popular on instagram
is i would do
i would do the same thing just for
instagram yeah it's a whole eat this not
that
uh on instagram totally great and and
the format is so good it's just a split
screen
so it has half the food item on the left
and half the food item on the right and
then it has the nutrition facts about
why
why one versus the other i think a lot
of this stuff is super shareable on
instagram and you would grow
very quickly like i can see their
instagram right now it looks kind of
shitty like they're not doing a great
job
i think you could basically steal this
concept pick a different name and uh
grow a big instagram account off this oh
yeah i was bored i would do something
like this
yeah and it's kind of a fun topic uh
i'm i'm reading all about it now this is
pretty amazing i hadn't thought about
this in forever but anyway
there you go i think uh uh if you did
that for six or
six or twelve months you get hundreds of
thousands of followers on
uh instagram um all right we'll switch
off food let's go to something else
what do you wanna talk about you want to
talk about money real quick tiller money
okay yeah what's this i have okay very
fascinating
do you you what do you use to track your
money
i don't use anything to track my money i
use excel okay
everyone says that oh i've talked to uh
not everyone but a lot of people here's
usually the answer right here
i use mint or i use personal capital or
i use
i have man tia as well and what can i
ask you why don't you use mint
uh i used mints back in the day i mean i
used mint like 10 years ago so it's just
kind of like one of those things that
i don't have a habit of going and
looking at and i don't like looking at
uh that stuff because it makes me focus
on like you know
expenses and saving money here and there
and i just don't think that's fun i
don't enjoy that so i'll i went and
looked at a bunch of subreddits about
money
uh because i usually use personal
capital and i don't like it for a bunch
of reasons right now
but when i asked like 10 different
people how they track their money
most who i ask maybe five or six use
excel which is kind of crazy to me
because how many
how many accounts do you have that you
need to track over 10
yeah yeah so it doesn't matter if you're
wealthy or not wealthy most people
like between if they have a wife or a
husband you have like your checking
account bank account your 401k
your stock stuff uh maybe your home loan
credit card credit card you probably
have two or three credit cards so
typically
i imagine the average joe has 10 plus so
it's actually a lot
to track regardless of if you have money
and everyone i've noticed
or not everyone a lot of people have
noticed use excel so i did some research
there's this thing and it's not like
i've discovered this i think it's pretty
popular already
called tiller money and all it is the
landing page is beautiful
but i'm just fascinated by this business
all it is is a
if you go to google sheets and you click
tools and then add-on
okay you'll see the ability to add
plug-ins to google sheets
okay tiller money all it is is a plug-in
for google sheets that costs 100 i think
it's 100
a year and all it does is it
automatically imports your bank accounts
and any other account into google sheets
and templates that they have or you can
just make your own template
but i've never seen someone build such a
sick and awesome business
off of a google sheet add-on it's it's
incredibly fascinating
yeah this is good i like this um i think
this is
this of all the like kind of money
manager things this appeals to me more
because it feels like i'm
managing my own money and uh in reality
you know the thing i'm always worried
about is data like i don't want my data
on all these different services like i'm
not going to try your new finance app
because like
i just don't want to link my bank
account to all this new stuff but uh
if they could do this where this was
like self-hosted in some way like it's
just a template
um that'd be great it doesn't look like
that's the case but it is sweet i like
it
so if you go to google sheets right now
and you click add-ons on the top right
once you're in a sheet
you can see add-ons and i actually just
realized i use a few add-ons the other
add-on i
use is called super metrics which is uh
it pulls in data from sql and stuff like
that
i'm i bet you they do close to eight
figures a year in in revenue
but uh we've talked about plug-ins for
wordpress we've talked about plug-ins
for
chrome google sheets plugins is another
thing
that is super super fascinating to me
and i completely overlooked it
uh it's so neat and so i don't know what
else to say other than it's cool
so you you had a thing that i thought
was kind of interesting that was about
open salaries what what is this and do
you want to talk about this or
or where do you want to go i'll let you
lead a little bit but i'll
i i it's so funny i'll i'll put stuff in
here throughout
like two weeks and
three days goes past and i'm like wait
did i write that or did you write that
so
all right so we'll do a quick we'll do
it quick so so you put this thing on
here i got kind of intrigued so you you
open salaries what is it uh it's the
idea that like today it's kind of crazy
that
we don't know what other people make and
not in a gossip kind of way but
it's really you know the company knows
what everybody makes
but the employees don't know and that
actually puts the employees at a pretty
big disadvantage you don't know when
you're underpaid you don't know if
there's any like
systemic bias and let's say women or
minorities are not getting paid as much
as
you know tall white males or whatever
and so um it's kind of weird that this
is this like taboo thing nobody talks
about it you're not allowed to talk
about it it's
seen as kind of a faux pas but it would
actually be to the benefit
of any employee to know to have
transparency
at as to what people are getting paid
and it can be anonymized but
being able to see what what other people
at your role at your company are getting
paid
and so you would put this thing on here
that colorado was gonna say that hey
from 2021
employers have to disclose pay rates and
ranges for job posts
um of any job that could be working in
colorado including remote jobs which i
thought was kind of interesting
and then we have companies like buffer
and whole foods have been doing this for
a while buffer kind of
tried to like make a name for themselves
by being like the open transparent
company we'll share everybody's salary
and like literally you can
like here's a link you can go and see
everybody at buffer's
salad whole foods let's do whole foods
you can see people's salary
uh you put that in there or a braided i
don't know i haven't seen that one but i
wanted to share a couple interesting
things i i found when i was digging into
this so first
uh check out this spreadsheet of buffer
salaries i just put it in the chat
so you can click this anybody can google
this and find it
you can go and you can see that joel the
ceo is making 280 thousand dollars this
year
and you can go see what the what his ea
is making she's making 89
000 and you can just go down the whole
company roster
everybody's salary is public which i
think is like
pretty insane um but interesting then
you have things like
the google kind of secret spreadsheets i
don't know if you've seen these but at
big companies people are starting to
like
just make an anonymous spreadsheet and
say hey
put in your salary and your level and
your your location here
um so we can all like have more
transparency you don't have to put your
name next to it
and um they circulated with inside
company so microsoft had one google had
one facebook had one and the google one
the the so i forgot who was some woman
created this and within two days ten
thousand people had put in their
information and now there's over twenty
thousand people
in the open google database and you can
link can you link to that
yeah it's right here um i have it at the
bottom um
so so so these are kind of cool and
um and it's interesting how viral these
go
so then i was looking at levels.fyi
which i know you know
about yeah yeah yeah it's a place to go
see like you can go and say all right
i'm interviewing at amazon and facebook
and they they labeled me an l5 software
engineer located in bay area like what
am i going to get paid how much is
or i got an offer i don't know if that
was a fair offer or a low offer did they
lowball me
and so you can go on levels at fyi and
it's the same thing crowdsourced
information about what you make
at these different companies and levels
if you look at their traffic they're
getting about a million and a half
visits a month and like there this thing
is really elevated from a side project
to something like pretty legit so they
have like job boards now
if you click at the top they actually
have the thing we were talking about
last episode a negotiator as a service
so if you hit the top it's a sick little
website where they have a little
calculator that says you know
what company where are you located how
many years of experience here's what
you're getting
here's what we think you should get paid
based on the levels database which is
now in the i don't know
tens of thousands of entries or
something like that and then
they basically say hey if you pay us 500
bucks we'll negotiate your offer for you
we have former recruiters from these
companies
that freelance with us and basically you
book a time you talk about your offer
and how you're feeling about it and what
you
what you really want out of this and
then we'll negotiate for you and they
show all these like success stories of
like this person
at facebook got 20 000 more than their
offer this person got 40 000 more this
person got 10 000 more
and so they're taking and they just take
a flat fee of like whatever 500 600
bucks i think
and um so i think there's some
interesting stuff going on in this like
transparency around what people are
making
and it really goes and like fits in my
values where
um i think it's crazy that people don't
talk about money more
i think it would help everybody if we
talked about money more and it would be
less
like kind of taboo and less uh less like
a big
deep dark secret if people were more
open about it and i think that's right
can i give you a counter point for that
go for it i thought that that was
interesting
and i'm not saying how i feel because
i'm still thinking about it but
leo i forget his name leo but
he did it from buffer the co-founder of
buffer who no longer works there
so buffer started with this whole
transparency thing
um that was like the whole shtick and it
worked out about everything
users revenue salaries everything it was
it was a stick that got popular amongst
bloggers
in particular there's this guy named pat
and he has this blog called
smartpassiveincome.com i used to read it
when i was
15 or 16 or 18 something like that in
high school
and he would make money by creating
books and doing
a bunch of other side businesses and he
would reveal his income every single
month
and other bloggers copied him and it was
a really cool thing john lee dumas did
it all these like really cool people did
it
buffer did it and that was their stick
to get popular and it worked because
the buffalo buffers product isn't really
special
it there's so many uh different versions
and they did it
uh leo uh leo said in an interview
someone was like dude this whole
transparency thing it's pretty cool like
you guys got traffic and everything do
you think that it would work and i
believe
i don't want to quote them because i i
saw this a year and a half ago two years
ago but something like
this works now and it's great for us but
i have a feeling when we get to 75 80 90
100 people
it's not gonna work anymore and it's
actually gonna hurt us big time
and i forget exactly why but i believe
steve
man i'm getting all my names screwed up
someone else had apple like a hedgehog
apple said something similar he's like
no the transparency thing it actually
can hurt it hurts the company after a
while we tried it and so i actually
think that maybe this is good for
startups
but it kind of sucks after a long time
because look
let's say you own a small business that
does 20 million in sales
and you're the business owner and you
want to pay yourself three million
dollars a year
that's pretty shitty then if you're a 50
receptionist or something but that's
like your right to do that
why would you want to share that with
everyone yeah as the employer
it's not great right buffer used it to
get a bunch of traffic because there's
it was an effective growth tactic for
them hey if we're open about this we'll
get a bunch of people
asking what the heck is buffer and some
of them will use it but uh
as the employer it's not great as the
employee it's great and so that's it
depends kind of which side of the coin
are you on
also it depends how far you go the
buffer thing where they write
everybody's name and how much they make
bit much but the google thing where it's
like hey look there's
thousands of employees here i need to
know that within my level
within my kind of area am i underpaid
overpaid or you know somewhere in
between
um it gives people peace of mind and and
it gives them
you know an opportunity to get more sort
of fairness or equity
in terms of being able to negotiate with
information information that the other
side has that you don't have
so i like it from the employee
perspective and i think it's
but i wouldn't go the buffer way of
writing everybody's names down now at a
small company
cool that kind of happens but i thought
that was
i think it's kind of cool i think
there's definitely interest around this
so
you know a couple little ideas of things
that people could do so levels f
dot fyi is cool is working um
i'm surprised that somebody like you
know our buddy andrew wilkinson doesn't
go buy a company like this um
it's it's kind of a n of one company it
has like a unique data advantage
it's in it does job boards which he
loves as a business model on top of all
this traffic that they're getting
and it's kind of like a side project
that's probably like you know
reach the max of that of which you know
the two guys behind it really can take
it
um the other ways that you could do this
i think you could do this in any
vertical so i don't know is there a
level of fyi in the
like hedge fund world or consulting or
banking
like if you're in those worlds and there
isn't a tool like this
you should just make the levels that fyi
database for your industry nursing i
don't know
whatever the industry is that this
product can work across those
um and so i think that's cool even
within levels somebody could go further
and be like all right i'm going to take
product managers or data science and
really own that
if they were somebody who has a big
audience for that like if if that guy
lenny um lenny who's got a big blog and
kind of audience around product managers
he could do this for product management
and do it better than levels can
generally so
i think the levels concept could be
exported and done in different
areas when we first launched like maybe
the first couple months of launching so
we didn't have an audience so
and i'm saying this so anyone could do
it we didn't have an audience um i wrote
a post called
how much money do founders make because
i was trying to figure out like do i pay
myself do i not pay myself
right whatever and if you google how
much money do founders have in their
bank account the hustle you might see it
and all i did was i took a google form
and i posted it on hacker news
and it went to number one uh they
eventually took it down because i think
that goes against their terms of service
like
i have a survey but i got like three or
four hundred
replies and i asked people how much
money they have in their checking
account how much they have in their bank
account how much they pay themselves how
much
do they have in illiquid assets i got
100 and then what their job title is and
where they live and i got hundreds of
replies and i published
all the data and i took out any
information where you could like learn
about someone and people
loved sharing anonymous information and
they
loved reading anonymous information like
they loved
like it was amazing and so i agree
i think it's pretty sick and it was way
oh there it is i bet you posted it
uh it was way easier to get people's i'm
not like
literally getting their information
because it's all anonymous but people
were
so forthcoming with us it was pretty
cool and pretty interesting
yeah i want somebody to do this with vcs
um i think most people don't know how
much vcs make
and all the different people in the food
chain like the gps versus like a partner
versus like an
associate or whatever and um i feel like
somebody should like kind of crack that
egg open and be like look
here's the here's the numbers here's
what it is and anonymize it
um but give people some transparency
into what what's really going on
let's talk about this for a second so
there's two companies that come to mind
that are interesting to me
when we're talking about this the first
is pitch book you know what pitch book
is yes do you pay for it it's so
expensive no my sister-in-law works
there though
and so every once well she'll she'll be
kind enough and let me ask her a
question of like
to look up uh no i don't pay for it
because it's really expensive it's like
25 000
i think yep um so pitch book it's kind
of like crunch base but souped up and so
you pay 25 grand
and you get access to like a lot of
information
about privately held companies uh the
second well let's just talk about pitch
book
the reason it's interesting is they have
a team of outsourced folks
i don't know which country they're in
but i think the philippines and
they literally have like 200 people and
and
by the way pitchbook is a publicly
traded company you can go and read about
them they're owned by morningstar so you
could actually go and see their
operations and how they
how they work they're growing like crazy
they're have north of 100 million in
revenue
you can they have a team of folks and
what they do is
call vcs and they literally just ask
them information or they call companies
and they just ask them information and
for some reason i don't know how or why
people give them information and that's
one of the ways one of many of ways that
they get
data the second thing is this uh
business called is it called the org
is that what it's called yes okay the
org
very interesting because in a nutshell
the tagline is the org transparency
starts here
build a better organization with a
public org chart celebrate your
colleagues
basically that's just kind of crap let's
not let's not read their marketing
yeah really what it is i mean i'm sure
they do all that nonsense but it's a
photo it's an org chart it's a public
org chart
yeah you pay money and you get access to
people's org chart and this
helps you know who to email to sell [__]
to right exactly
uh and that's cool like there's no i
don't know why they don't just say that
but
they've raised a lot of money like i
think tens of millions of dollars
it's probably gonna be a monster
business and so
i would do two things with the salary
thing one i would actually hire
people in the philippines or whatever
and just hit it hard
and just go out and hit it hard and i
would trust that a lot of people would
be actually pretty
pretty transparent uh and the second
thing is i would pay wallet
kind of like the org and i would sell
this to every hr
uh department in the country
so i have a friend that is doing this
with shopify sales i showed him
a way to roughly estimate how much a
not roughly it's pretty good estimate
how much how many how much sales a
shopify store is doing
and um what is that what can i get you
don't have to save it true
is it because you order from them and
you see what the order number is
that's one of the ways yeah and that's
one of the best ways and so
i showed him i said look this is this is
useful people want to know what their
competitors are doing and the second way
is you look at the traffic
uh yeah you still need a couple other
pieces of information for example you
need to know how much the average order
is and things like that but
um but roughly that that will tell you
uh you know how they're doing
and so now he emails me a report
every month that shows me you know these
four companies that i decided uh hey i
want to track these four companies
and emails we report this is their sales
this is their social media following
this is how many ads that they're
running on facebook
and um one other thing which is just
like the month over month changes uh
between those
and i think it's a great idea so he was
kind of looking for something to do i
told him look i think this is a good
pivot
uh i don't know exactly how well he's
doing i should really shout out the name
but i kind of don't remember let me look
it up while we're doing this
how did you find this person he was in
my mastermind
let me see what his thing is called it's
called
okay dramatic pause let me figure it out
and you came up with the uh
with the uh i told him i was like look
uh because he was like dude i'm good
with data i'm interested in
this kind of stuff um but i also like
you know i also have a team in the
philippines and um
you know so so i really like this okay
so here it is so
the the website is shopsalesdata.com
and uh i hope he gets a bunch more
customers from this
i hope he's still doing it um he still
emails me my report i hope he's taking
more customers right now
but it's a monthly report of shopify
competitor data
in your inbox every month for 100 or
something like that
yeah this is great i mean you could do
the same with um facebook ad accounts
just like because facebook shows
everyone their ads you can say
you know email me my competitors ads
every time they launch a new one
exactly and so i think that there's like
there's some good stuff in this kind of
like data
data-based businesses where you're just
collecting data from public sources
you're cleaning it up you're structuring
it
and then you're offering it as a service
to a bunch of other
companies okay you want to do a mini one
do we have a mini one
uh yeah let's do a quick one what else
we got um
do you have anything good of like your
first week working at a real job
it is was my first week and now it's in
my second week and i'm sitting on a
beach in hawaii
uh so working doing it
having a job rocks
i should have done this years ago i love
having a job
um it's cool man hubspot announced that
they had a billion dollars in revenue
like uh run rate it's pretty amazing and
so there's like two
things this is like my first like real
job uh or like a
corporate job um i mean that's not
exactly true like
i would have friends like my friend
neville who
is like a works for himself he would be
like hey you want to go hang out on a
wednesday like at noon i'm like no dude
i have a job
like right so i treat like running my
company it was 100
more more than a job it's two jobs yeah
it's more than it's i would call it a
nine to five i'm like yeah like i'm
it was in fact way more than nine to
five but i was like i'm like pretty
straight
like i get to work at nine i do my thing
like
anyway so i i tease about this but
yeah first like corporate job um
it's it's gonna slow down
but like the amount of meetings is
pretty crazy and i told them i'm not
doing meetings like this anymore
um because i'm gonna make stuff but i
don't know
how it's still crazy to me how people
find time
to get the actual work done yeah
i uh i realized how that works which is
just that managers don't get work done
managers just go to meetings and then
ics or individual contributors as
they're known
are the ones who actually like sit down
and do work because they don't have
you know back-to-back meetings
throughout the day
but i think even like your work is
basically just communicating between
people
but my seven days of working has shown
me that even
ics have a lot of meeting yeah like they
should they shouldn't they should not
have that many they should have like
whatever one or two or three a day but
uh they should have like you know
somewhere between three and five hours
of uninterrupted
time yeah like so is that a like i just
don't understand how people so like
i'm telling everyone that husband i'm
like you don't no one talked to me for
these hours
i had i like like and i'm like this is i
and i and i say i say it nicely of
course but i say uh i'm doing this for
the better of everyone like i'm gonna
make good stuff
so like let me go up my hole and you
just just don't bother me all right
what's been the worst part so far
the meetings let's be um okay what what
what me with the meetings boring or just
the amount of them
the amount and also like i didn't know
what workday is and all this stuff
there's just so much paperwork that i've
always had people do for me that i'm
having to do
um what's the worst part uh you know
like everyone's like is having a boss
weird because i've never had a boss
before
no i think it's gonna suck after a while
of course like having a boss might suck
i'm so pumped i don't have to like i get
to just
shovel [__] onto karen's plate that i
don't like i'm like hey
you know should we hire this person like
i don't have to make that decision
i love that i love that i think it's
awesome um
so having a boss has not sucked so far
um
i don't know what do you think would be
the worst parts and i'll tell you if
they are what was your worst part
there are certain meeting types that you
have to do
that i just found like completely soul
sucking one of them was called a
calibration meeting
it's basically like uh even just
describing it
you know gives me some pain here
basically it's like
you're trying to promote people but how
do you know like if every manager
has their own criteria for promotions
how do you make sure you're promoting
people equally and fairly
throughout the company so you have to do
these things called calibration meetings
or you sit down and you basically say
this person's up for promotion or they
get they're getting promoted because of
this this and this and then other person
says
well you know i i felt like they weren't
uh they weren't great at this or they
didn't do a great job with that project
and you have to kind of defend them
for me it was boring on two levels one
first
and foremost i didn't know anyone else
in the company so i just sat there for
three hours
not being able to say anything because i
didn't interact with any of these people
i just got here i just got bought i
don't know these people i can't give any
input
nor do i have any opinion on if the
feedback is valid or not and the second
thing i was just like wow
even after all this talk like i still
just feel like the person who's the most
uh vocal and best salesperson
is getting their way and the person
who's not that great at talking is not
getting their way
so like we could have just skipped all
this like it would have almost been
better
had we not gone into this room and said
you sell your person and you sell your
person and you
debate this person it's like the better
debater wins in big companies and i
think that that's like
really crazy well i think we do at our
company all the time which is like
if it will say i'll like if a meeting
says for 30 minutes
and and like in the meeting i'm like
okay i said what i had to say i don't
need to be here anymore i'm leaving
or like it's very it wasn't considered
rude to be like hey uh you need to leave
now you're done
uh it was like kind of a helpful thing
and i'm still trying to figure out how
to politely do that here i'm like
do you guys need me here can i can i
leave right or
or i'll just say i'm out i've said what
i need to say i've heard what i need to
hear
you guys can talk yeah um especially on
zoom or whatever you just sort of like
you hold up
you wave and you click exit the second
thing is
hubspot is doing really well and just
the software business and this sounds
like just like
like obvious stuff from anyone who's in
software but i've never been
at a company like this man if you figure
out how to get a
hav if you figure out how to reduce your
churn to
very little or or even positive so for
every dollar someone spends it's above
one dollar the next year
um and you pick a big enough market it's
just magical
like just now i understand why people
are saying like oh you know why is this
company
valued so high highly it's like well
because sticky revenue software revenue
so something like
i don't know if hubspot would be
considered this but something for sure
where you're building an entire business
off of the and you know that the
switching costs are quite high
um it's pretty amazing like software
like just start a software company it's
so much better than everything else
like it's really hard and it's slog
early on but
if it really truly if you can get your
churn to be right and you pick a big
enough market
it's just and you have a and you can
figure out how to have a good marking
machine which all this is like
oh yeah if only you could do that like i
know but
like you can kind of figure it out
actually i think giving it up if you if
you give yourself like five years to
figure it out i think you can
um well i think all the things you're
saying are true and they really just
point to this one lesson i've learned
the hard way over and over again which
is
it's much more important to pick what
game you play than to try to be the best
player at a game
because if you pick the wrong game even
becoming the best player still
ends up in a small outcome or a really
painful path
but if you pick the right game to play
and whether you become the best or
not even the best but you know just kind
of the top 25 percent
um it's just so much better to win that
way and
in this case like we've if we've we talk
about and we've done different types of
businesses right we've done
like i did social network i try to make
a new social network it's the wrong
[__] game to play dude it's so hard
um so hard so it's a low chance of
probability of success you did a media
business
also hard hard you know higher odds of
success but like
lower size of the price if you get it
right way lower size
um ecom you know just a [__] pain in
the ass just tons of headaches all the
time with your supply chain and
logistics because you get real world
products and you have to like
ship them all around the world and
you're gonna have customers who have
returns and like
things that just like are not as easy as
software
and so like we've and you know we talk
about all these different
you know doing a paid newsletter or
whatever like there's all these
different models
and for my money by far the best one
is to build a software business because
a software business can scale a software
business can like
be improved over time and you know
unlike e-commerce when you
when you make a crappy e-commerce
product uh you know you go make a better
version the next
you know it takes you six months to make
it and then you make it and all those
old customers who got the bad products
still think you suck
whereas with software you push the
update and all of a sudden every single
customer has the new best thing
you know there's all these just tiny
advantages and um
software is the way to go but we i want
to say something that david siegel so we
had david siegel on last time he had a
billion dollar or close to billion
dollar t business and i go david why are
you doing
brick and mortar stores when he could be
doing software and he said the right
thing
what did he say he was like oh it's fun
i love selling product
and i was like that's the best answer
that is a wonderful answer and i think
that like
will i ever be able to start an
enterprise software company
i think that if i was going to it would
either have to be very soon or even a
few years ago like you
i would you have to do it i think when
you're like really like where
money's the one number one thing it's
like i got to get paid i got to get my
hit
and um in that case yeah i would do
anything to make money
but where i am now and where i think
where a lot of people are is you
really it's f it's i agree with
everything you said but you have to add
the
and also not like passionate about but
what what what excites you enough to
that you're willing to get good at it
over a decade
right we'll flout your boat all right so
let's take you okay uh you're happy at
hubspot everything's great you're gonna
be there for for 20 years we know that
alternate reality you know we all know
you're happy to hub spot you'll be there
for
two decades it's great uh it's you know
sunshine and rainbows
let's say alternate reality they fire
you tomorrow you're gonna go build
something else
um where do you think you would go build
would you do what you're
would you go media would you go
something totally different would you go
software what do you think you would do
everyone's gonna laugh at me because i
say trucking but i would do some maybe
something something in the agriculture
space yeah i think ag tech is is
ag tech is interesting uh i think that's
the most interesting i had a great call
with this guy who
i'm gonna um we gotta have this guy in
the podcast his name's uh
uh his son's name is jordan i can't uh
rob
uh van trump it's called the van trump
report
so van trump report it's this guy who
has a newsletter that does 20 million
dollars a year
in subscription revenue he's the only
writer and he was telling me all about
ag tech do you know what act tech stands
for
yeah agricultural tech and he was just
saying all types of like what's going on
and i think working with like
middle america people who whether
they're rich or not they're
more humble and they create things that
actually impact the world like
get food to you i would do something in
that space or
i would start another media company but
okay let's say you go into ag tech
or and you're probably gonna be open and
whatever you know you'll think of it
then but
knowing what you know now would you do
media in agriculture would you do
uh you know something with actual farms
and logistics would you do
technology hard you know trucking actual
self-driving trucks would you do
uh a job thing would you what would you
what model would you be wanting to do in
that space
well okay so i don't like this question
because it
will change every single day you ask me
but as of right now i would start
a blog with in the ad tech space
and then eventually i would turn it into
a database kind of i like this
this company the org uh i think i could
create something
like a database that's better um
and yeah that's what i would do okay so
nice
i think that's what i would do as of
right now that that fascinates me or i
would create um
do you know what tiger 21 is isn't that
like a
like a kind of a conference or club or
mastermind thing or something it's like
a club for people who have investable
assets north of 10 million dollars
and it costs 30 grand a year it's and
they have like a thousand people who are
subscribed
and uh my friend joined and i looked at
the back end and it was horrible and i
was like oh i'm just going to clone that
and what do they do with the with the
members is it events or is it
uh it's like both
but like they create like um like little
like safe communities
where like you meet in groups of 10 and
you kind of show off your portfolio and
people criticize you
and like try to def make you defend your
position so you get better
but it got bought by private equity so
it makes a lot of money all right that's
cool
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off on the road less travel
never looking back